dans la commune de guyancourt c'est
françois morton maire sortant et tête de
liste de décidons ensemble à guyancourt
qui est réélu avec 51 points 47% des
voix
rodolphe baril est tête de liste
d'ensemble agissons plus guyancourt
arrive en deuxième position avec 32 0 4%
des voix et grégory pape tête de liste
de nouvel élan à guyancourt obtient
16,48 % des voix c'est une campagne qui
a été très longue
voilà très longue bien évidemment
puisque c'est inédit
trois mois entre les deux tours en ce
qui me concerne je suis devenu maire le
12 mai 2019
donc c'était effectivement une situation
aussi qu'ils étaient probablement
dangereuse
voilà pour pour la ville de guyancourt
et je suis absolument ravi d'avoir
établi leur en quelques semaines avant
les élections détention régné dans la
commune de voisins-le-bretonneux entre
olivier afonso tête de liste du nid pour
voisins et alexandra rosetti maire
sortante
c'est finalement alexandra rosetti qui
remporte l'élection avec 53 10 % des
voix contre 30 points 91 pour olivier
afonso béatrice pierrât tête de liste d'
avec vos voisins avance arrive en
troisième position avec 15 points 97 %
des voix ça a été tellement longue
tellement dure cette période entre les
six mois de campagne les mois de crise
et plus et perdent ce dernier mois avec
une fin de campagne absolument immonde
forcément je suis soulagé avec l' envie
de se mettre au travail rapidement
voilà avec cette nouvelle équipe à
plaisir avec 800 votes d'écart et 43
points 99 % des voix joséphine coleman
berger conserve son siège à la mairie et
pense déjà aux projets en cours pour la
ville face à elle patridge inter obtient
32 0 1% des voix
avec sa liste plaisir notre ville notre
avenir et annie joël prix ou hasseni
tête de liste de taff tout à faire pour
plaisir arrive en troisième position
avec 23 points 98 % des voix les cons
projets comme les projets de la maison
médicale qui va démarrer incessamment
sous peu on a aussi tout le grand projet
de l'éco quartier du val ippon on a
également tout le projet du centre bourg
ce sont des projets que nous n'avons pas
du tout arrêter et qui sont vraiment
dans cette dynamique de la tente des
plaisirs wa de développer les espaces
verts et des trains
dynamique là avec bien sûr l'arrivée de
tous liés assistance médicale puisque
nous avons trouvé des médecins on est
ravi les maires de ces trois communes
prendront place lors de leur conseil
d'installation le 3 juillet pour plaisir
et le 4 juillet pour voisins le
bretonneux et guyancourt